cutting through the waters of plymouth
sound without
any human control the mayflower 400
is completely autonomous with an
artificially intelligent computer in
charge
and it's about to navigate 3 000 miles
across some of the world's busiest
shipping lanes to america
with satellite maps of nearby ships and
six onboard cameras
it can spot hazards and stay around them
so it's looking at all those positions
and then it's scanning 12 miles around
with its radar
and then it's looking with its cameras
and it's fusing it's like okay that
is a radar contact and that's a picture
of the thing i see on the radar
and it's got a beacon on it that i can
see through my satellites that says it's
this kind of ship and it's going this
fast in this direction
and then using the radar and the cameras
it sort of validates that it's like yep
that's that ship and it is doing what it
says it's doing i have to turn or speed
up or slow down
so that i obey the rules and cross the
right way
without humans on board there's no need
for bunks toilets or a kitchen
it's pure machine in future even cargo
vessels are likely to have an
artificially intelligent captain that
takes over out at sea
but this is a marine research ship
the ocean covers 70 percent of the
planet but just
five percent has been explored it's so
vast that much of it is beyond the reach
of scientists
until now inside the hull
robotic instruments will test the sea
water climate change is making the
oceans warmer and more acidic
putting marine life under pressure
plankton the bottom of the food chain
will be monitored
and the ship will also listen to wales
to gauge how many there are in the open
ocean
the ocean impacts us all far more than
we may even realize you know it's not
just
the food that we eat it's our travel our
trade
and above all it's our climate as well
the ocean regulates our planet to a huge
extent
it also produces half of the oxygen that
we breathe
so it is it's hugely vital we really
need to
up our game to start to have innovation
like this and take advantage of the
technology that's
out there now it should take around a
fortnight to cross the atlantic
400 years ago the original mayflower
took early settlers to america
its namesake is another pioneer sailing
the seas on its own
to check the health of the ocean thomas
more sky news in plymouth